Speaker 1: As we await the possible first
federal and second overall indictment and
arrest of the twice impeached, once indicted
failed former President Donald Trump.
Some devastating news that Trump has
broken, and that is that Mark Meadows,
his own former chief of staff, has already
testified, has already testified. We are going
to look at a report about this and discuss why
it is such a big deal. Newsweek reports Donald
Trump suffers the worst hit yet in a string of
legal blows, and it reads, Donald Trump is facing
further legal headaches amid suggestions his
former chief of staff has testified to a grand
jury as part of two federal investigations into
the former president. Remember, there are two
federal investigations into Trump. One relates
to the document fiasco, Mar a Lago, Bedminster,
the drained pool into the surveillance room.
That entire thing, that alone is bonkers. Then
there's the additional federal investigation
related to what the January 6th committee
from the last Congress referred to the Justice
Department involving January 6th, the Trump riots,
etc.. Back to the article. Several media outlets
have reported that Mark Meadows has answered
questions under oath after being subpoenaed
by special counsel Jack Smith. He is leading
the probes into Trump's attempts to overturn 2020
and his actions on January 6th and the classified
documents. Meadows is said to have answered
questions relating to both criminal investigations
into the former president while appearing in front
of the grand jury, per ABC News. Meadows has long
been considered a key figure in the criminal
investigation into these events. Meadows has
gained additional significance as part of
the classified documents probe after reports
emerged. Remember, we covered this last week that
there is audio of Trump admitting in July of 2021
he had retained a secret Pentagon paper and
it was classified, which confirms that Trump
didn't actually believe that he had declassified
it. So let's cut right to the chase with this,
because there's really like the core kernel
of this at the center. Why is the testimony
of Mark Meadows so potentially disastrous for
Donald Trump? MEADOWS At the critical moment.
At which all of this stuff was going on was
Trump's closest ally and confidant in the White
House. We know this. There's no doubt about
it whatsoever. Meadows knows everything about
Trump's attempts to overturn the 20 election, 2020
election, to incite the January 6th insurrection.
He certainly knows about Trump's apparently,
and potentially illegal retention of retention
of classified documents, which have all sorts
of different implications. And so it is the
Meadows testimony. Above anyone else we can even
hypothetically think of, that could be the crucial
evidence, not by itself, but in addition to
everything else provided by other witnesses
and other testimony for these two federal
investigations being led by special counsel Jack
Smith. This really is the nightmare scenario for
Donald Trump. Trump has been desperately trying
to avoid scrutiny, of course, but to avoid
accountability and legal jeopardy for his actions.
He has said he had the authority to declassify
any document he wanted, even if he didn't have
access to them or even if he didn't have the legal
right to do so. But then we figured out, oh, he
knowingly said, I have classified documents after
this period where the supposedly declassification
took place. Meadows is the top guy who can testify
to what Trump believed, knew, thought and said at
the time. Remember that Trump also tried to block
former aides from cooperating with Congress and
with the Justice Department. He tried invoking
these bogus claims of executive privilege and
threatening people with lawsuits. And he even,
quite frankly, he even seemed to have potentially
a witness tampering. Okay. There are
allegations that there was witness tampering,
although that's something that has to be proven
in court. So we'll stop there. But the Trump
legal strategy doesn't appear to have actually
worked. Courts have repeatedly rejected his
claims of privilege and immunity. They've allowed
prosecutors and investigators to access documents
and witnesses. And when we talk about Meadows,
they want to talk to Steve Bannon and on and on.
This is potentially the one individual who
could most jeopardize Donald Trump legally.
This is the most serious legal peril that Trump
has faced in his life. He has only himself to
blame. He's abused power. He's violated his
oath of office. He's certainly betrayed the
country. He's endangered countless lives in
many different ways. And he. Forget about
remorse. Forget about repentance. He doesn't
even pretend to be sorry for any single aspect
of this and only blames other people and
says he's the biggest victim in the world.
So the news of Mark Meadows reportedly testifying
could be the most devastating single event in the
entire series of Trump investigations. And we will
soon. But by the time this video and this episode
publish, we may already know more about the
Trump federal indictment than we know right now.